A long time ago in a labretorium far away ...
Welcome to Science Wars
Chemistry, Bio, Physics and Mathematics!
Which field is the best?
(PHYSICS)
I understand the power and energy
quantum mechanics and relativity
My field is pure and they trust in me
I see the universe like no other
You may have mocked me in high school
To be uncomfortable and follow the rules
Now I have readers. (Wow that very cool)
May the mass times be acceleration with you
ATOMS!
ENTROPY!
DARK MATERIAL!
STRINGTOERIE!
(CHEMISTRY)
If you want to feel a band
Then I'll give you a good response
The element that makes me is the essence
Is my satisfaction
All the other fields out there are so basic
Yes, I am the central science
Keep your eye on me, I'll get you loaded
If you need me, call me at Avogadro's number
If you let me go, take a titrant and press it on your acid buffer
Dopamine and serotonin will keep you well and happy
So get your bottle and your glass set up
And start to understand the world!
(BIOLOGY)
Inside you will find life its beauty
From genetics to ecology
Symbiosis and not section
Except if it is mitosis or the study of fission
Even if you don't get through, you'll at least enjoy my class!
Evolution brought us together
All species sing a song
(Mathematics)
If you want to learn about our planet I have to say
I'm the purest field of study you can take
Immune to misinterpretation
The blueprint of creation
The backbone of all science
No benefit, just a constant addition
In your mind and observation
No devices, just logic and your time
And PI
Together we will find the answers to life!
With Physics - Biology - Chemistry - and Mathematics
Can we science!